of the tools available to an actor the
real the IMDB page the resume the agent
or the manager is there one that stands
out as the best that you could really
have without the rest or no the internet
movie database page is the best tool
that an actor has because it's the most
visible one so I'm gonna pimp that page
out I know actors and actresses who
don't have pictures on their page very
bad you know loaded up with pictures and
not just pictures you think of pretty
with pictures which show your brand and
I some people who will do like you know
I want to show my versatility every
picture looks different i'm not a fan of
that I think you should constantly
reinforce what it is that you do also on
that page you can put your demo reel up
and you should you I think you're
allowed something like four or five demo
reels put those clips up and finally a
trick that I learned from Danny Trejo
from looking at his page there's a
section of IMDB which is called
trademarks and that's where you can list
things that the actor actress is known
for and it's the same theory as the bio
what would you like to be known for say
that you're known for it and that if you
do all of these things then when people
go to your IMDB page they will see a
complete picture of who you are as an
actor what you do what your brand is and
it makes it very very easy to consider
you to be hired because you're a
complete commodity there what if you
have the IMDB page the real the resume
but not the actor a manager is that only
good for a certain level and then after
a point you can't really progress
without the actor
yes it true you do need management be at
a manager or an agent and in my case I
have both but for years I just had the
manager it's been tremendously helpful
to me I think you need that you need the
outside I of someone who looks at the
overall spear of your career are you
gonna pay them you're gonna pay them
it's fifteen percent of your income you
know your your agent ten fifteen percent
of your income but that's money that you
wouldn't have had and I know actors who
said oh you know I don't want to get a
manager because I don't want to pay the
Commission but then you don't get their
roles that would bring you the money to
pay the Commission anyway so yes but
again that internet movie database is
very very important because if you are
approaching someone to be your
representation that's the first thing
they're going to look at do you know how
to market yourself do you have a clear
idea of who you are as an actor and it
makes their job a lot easier if you do
on the flip side what about the actor
that gets that agent or manager and then
sits by the phone or watch this
Nicholson movies during the day if
you're sitting by the phone waiting for
your agent to call you should go home
wherever home is because you're not
gonna make it I hear this all the time
my agent does nothing for me my manager
does nothing for me I get ninety eight
percent of my work on my own and then
the deals are negotiated through my
representation I will send them leads
here's someone who's interested in
working with me and they not only or
anything for about a week and then I get
a call back saying we've done the deal
here it is what do you think my job is
to develop the leads and that's my work
I never ever ever look to my agent or my
manager to bring me work that's not
their job not their job I don't wait for
the phone to ring if it does that's just
gravy but I'm always working myself
again if that's the mindset please don't
come to LA because there's too many
starving people here so again going i
always use real estate
it's like you're a realtor you're
hanging your license with the broker yes
great you've got that locked in now
you're looking on the MLS for homes
excellent analogy that's exactly what it
means it just means that when you're
when you were trying to promote yourself
as the realtor you can say I'm
associated with ABC agency and it just
gives you a little added stature but you
still have to do the work yourself this
is work that actors don't like to do
because we just want to act you know all
on the same way I just want to act but
that's the such a small tip of the
iceberg such a small part of my job
you